في مثل هذه الكوارث المروعه تكثر الاسئله
حول كيفيه اسعاف الناجين ليس فقط من
الناحيه الطبيه ولكن من الناحيه النفسيه
في ظل ما عينوه من اهوال ولا يقتصر الامر
فقط على الناجين والضحايا بل يتعداهم
لهؤلاء الذين يقومون باعمال الاغاثه
والذين يعيشون ظروف عمل صعبه ويتعاملون مع
احداث انسانيه مؤلمه تنضم الينا من بيروت
استاذه علم النفس العيادي في الجامعه
اللبنانيه الدكتوره نيبال الحاج محمد اهلا
بك دكتور نيبال دكتوره نيبال ما هي الاثار
النفسيه التي تخلفها هذه الكوارث على من
نجوا وعلما ساهموا وعملوا في عمليات
الانقاذ وماذا عن الاطفال
مساء الخير للجميع بطبيعه الحال عزائنا
لارواح
الضحايا اللي سقطوا وايضا
الرحمه لهم والعزاء
بالدرجه الاولى لاهاليهم ولا من بقي منهم
على قيد الحياه بطبيعه الحال هي كارثه
انسانيه بامتياز العنصر المباركه او
المفاجئه دائما بالكوارث الطبيعيه بيكون
له اثار نفسيه بتظهر على الاشخاص بنسب
متفاوته ولكن لما لا شك فيه انه
كاختصاصيين نفسانيين نتوقع معاناه هول
الاشخاص على مدى اسابيع ما بعد الازمه او
الكارثه من اضطراب ضغوط ما بعد الصدمه بي
تي اس دي حالات ديستراس قويه تتخطى حالات
ستريس ضغوط النفسيه الاعتياديه وفي البعض
منكم منهن ممكن انه تظهر عليه هذه الاعراض
بعد سنه وحتى سنوات يعني مش ضروري
بعد فتره قريبه من الحادثه في منهم وهيدا
خطوره الوضع انه بتظهر عليهم اعراض نفسيه
مثل ما قلت
ايضا
مره اخرى ما الذي يجب مراقبته من سلوك لدى
الافراد وخاصه الاطفال بعد مرور فتره
زمنيه من الكارثه
عندهم الاشخاص اللي ننصح انه يكون في مثل
ما عم نشوف على وسائل التلفزيون حالات
الاستنفار من قبل الصليب الاحمر والدفاع
المدني الموجود بهذه البلاد يكون في كمان
حاله استنفار من الناحيه النفسيه يعني
وزارات الصحه بهيدي البلاد اللي هي
بالاساس صارت عندهم الزلزال وتاثروا بشكل
مباشر لازم يكون في برامج الدعم النفسي
وبالتالي مساعده هون الاشخاص على تخطي
الازمه من الاعراض اللي ممكن نشوفها
اضطراب
ما يعرف بالسعر بيولوجيه
بجسمهم مثل الاكل الشهيه النوم بالاضافه
لحاله من الانسوميا الارق
حاله من الاسلاف الوجداني بشعروا فيها انه
هم عندهم الرغبه انه يبتعدوا فيه عن
الاخرين حاله من الترقب من الحذر وحاله
ايضا من الاحباط والياس والشعور بالقلق
القلق من المستقبل وقلق من المجه لانه
كمان بدنا ننظر انه لمساله كتير مهمه
ندور عليها واللي هي انه الناجين من
الزلزال ومن هيدي الكارثه الطبيعيه هن
بطبيعه الحال رح يعانوا من التشرد من
البطاله وخصوصي بهيك ظروف يعني مناخير منا
مساعده منشان هيك نحن بندعي دائما انه
يكون في هذا الدعم المادي والمعنوي مباشره
بعد حدوث هذه الكوارث من اجل التخفيف من
ظهور هذه الارض من خلال التجارب السابقه
يعني هل تظهر الاعراض بشكل اكبر على
الاطفال ام على الكبار والراشدين
طبعا بالنسبه لهذا لهذا الموضوع نحن
بنتوقع انه يكون الاطفال وحتى النساء هم
الاشخاص اللي عاده
اكثر بطبيعه يعني بطبيعه الحال ولكن فيما
يتعلق باعراض ضغوط ما بعد الصدمه واعراض
الديستريس بتتراوح حدتها وشدتها طبعا
لسمات شخصيه عند هول الناس
فيثبت علميا انه اذا في اشخاص سبق وهنروا
بحياتهم بتجارب سابقه من
الصدمات ممكن يكونوا عرضه للمعاناه
بمستويات اعلى فيما يتعلق بخضوع او مرورهم
بصدمات اخرى مستقبليا بس بدي احكي عن
موضوع كثير مهم انه بحاله الاشخاص اللي
الناجين من الكوارث الطبيعيه او الكوارث
اللي هي من صنع الانسان مثل بالحروب منضوي
على مساله كتير مهمه او اللي هي غير
معاناته من اضطراب ضغوط ما بعد الصدمه
ممكن يعانوا من من عقده اسمها عقده
الناجين من من الحرب او من الكارثه
الطبيعيه شعور بالذنب نحن بنسميها
يعني احساسهم بانه نحن كنا بنفس اللوكيشن
بنفس الازمه نحن بقينا على قيد الحياه في
حين انه الاخرين ماتوا بحسوا باعراض اللي
هي بتتركز حول شعور بملامه او لون الذات
هل كنا ممكن انه يساعدهم هالكين بمادونا
انه نحن ننقذهم ليه نحن باينين على قيد
الحياه والباقيين لا طبعا مثل ما قلت هي
اعراض ضغوط ما بعد الصدمه
الضغط النفسي الشديد بالاضافه لعقده
النجاه وهذا لازم
دكتوره ان نقدم شيئا للاخرين طيب هنا سؤال
لو سمحت طيب في حين انه هن المسؤولين
بطبيعه الحال عن اللي صار ولكن هو خلينا
نقول عارض من ضمن الاعراض واللي بيضوي بس
بدي اقول انه دليل التشخيصي والاحصائي
للاضطرابات العقليه الدي اس ام
النسخه الحديثه او المحدثه اللي هي ريليز
مؤخرا بتحكي عن عارض الشعور بالندم واللوم
الذات من ضمن حتى منظومه اذا بدك الاعراض
اللي هي تصف اعراض ضغوط مع بعض الصدمه اذا
لو سمحت قصدي زائد
النجاه من الازمه او من واحد منهم
نبسط الموضوع اكثر تحدثتي بانه لا بد من
وجود فرق لمعالجه الحالات النفسيه الناتجه
عن هكذا كوارث نحن نعلم بان هذا صعب لا
سيما في الشمال السوري الذي يعاني من نقص
حتى في الغذاء وحتى في المناطق في في
تركيا لن تتواجد هذه الفرق بالتالي ما
النصائح التي ممكن ان تعطيها للاهالي في
التعامل خاصه مع الاطفال او مع الذين نجوا
الذين لديهم هذه الاعراض التي قد تظهر
عليهم بعد فتره هل يتحدثون عن الموضوع
يتجاهلونه تماما ما الحلول
نعم بطبيعه الحال ممكن تفعيل خدمه الخط
الساخن يعني باي بلد بالعالم حتى لو كنا
نتحدث عن مناطق بعيده لناحيه الجغرافيه او
ظروف يعني صعبه لناحيه الوصول الى هذه
المناطق كما تفضلت سواء بالشمال السوري او
غير ذلك من يعني شو ما كانت الوضعيه ممكن
تفعيل خدمه الخط الساخن لمن خلال بتلقوا
هون للاشخاص الدعم النفسي لا حين وصول فرق
الانقاذ والمساعده اذا نحن هون عم نحكي عن
حاله استنفار نفسي مش بس على صعيد مثل ما
تفضلتوا ببدايه
الريبورتاج او انه اليوم مش المطلوب بس
انه نساعدهم ماديا واسعافات على الصعيد
يعني الجروح والكدمات الجسديه لابد انه
يتم الالتفات لمساله الاستنفار ايضا على
صعيد تقديم الخدمات النفسيه وه ننصح ونحذر
انه عدم
الاسراع بتقديم الدعم النفسي ولو شي
منسميه نحن الاسعافات النفسيه الاوليه عبر
طوائم ممكن يكون فيها اختصاصيين نفسيين
يقدروا يوصلوا
يعني المكانات او السيارات العسكريه بركه
بهيدا البلد بكل بلد فيه دايما سيكولوجيس
او اختصاصيين نفسيين اللي ممكن هن يبادروا
لتقديم المساعده مثل ما قلت الوزاره
الوزارات الموجودين بالبلاد المنكوبه سواء
كان عم نحكي عن وزاره الاعلام او وزاره
الشؤون الاجتماعيه او وزاره الصحه او
وزاره الداخليه لازم يفعلوا خدمه الخط
الساخن اللي من خلاله بنقدر نحن نخفف على
عن هول الاشخاص لحين وصول المساعدات
اللوجستيه على الارض عبر الهوريكا
الطيارات عبر المروحيات عبر اليات عسكريه
كان ما كان لازم توصل هذه الفرق الدعم
النفسي لان في خطوره اذا تاخر الدعم
النفسي وصوله او تامينه لهون لاشخاص ممكن
تظهر عندهم اعراض ضغوط ما بعد الصدمه
بطريقه كتير قويه وكثير شديده على المدى
القريب والمدى البعيد
علم النفس العيادي في الجامعه اللبنانيه